halle-loo it's me shangela and I'm so
excited to be here at BuzzFeed today
honey
yes chatting it up about the new film a
stars board which is in theaters now
okay but first we're gonna play a little
game all about first first word that
comes to your mind when you hear a
lip-synch for your life
well I can tell you the first feeling
it's a shudder okay well I would say the
first word would be death drop because
that was the first time I ever death
drop on television was a RuPaul's Drag
Race Season three when I was doing the
share believe lip-synch for your life in
the bottom two I didn't want to go home
and honey I said you know what I do
believe the first time I met Lady Gaga
was during the applause music video
filming and can I tell a funny story
real quick I don't know if it's gonna be
funny but it's a story
Lady Gaga at the time was working with
my friend Perry meek Perry sends me this
message says honey the lady that's we
called it the lady has requested that
you and Courtney act appear in a lyric
video for the song applause as I'm doing
on my performance the person on stage
with the camera the camera man it's like
all on me and I just see the camera in
this guy he's all and I'm like okay
thank you baby but you know I'm trying
to perform for Gaga I take my hand and
just slightly shifted the cameraman to
the left like baby let me handle this
baby okay then I notice that everyone in
the audience has their cell phones and
they're filming the cameraman and I'm
like oh hello I'm on stage so I turn and
look to see whatever I look at girl the
cameraman was Lady gaga she was videoing
the whole thing herself so I'm like oh
Lord I'm never gonna get a booking again
you know and she was going you know see
that literally up don't anyhow it worked
out well and after the video I was
finished filming she came upstairs to
the dressing room and she was so like
you wouldn't know that she was like Lady
gaga because she was so down-to-earth
and sweet
and like just like super warm and first
of all she was like oh I've been waiting
to get back to a club and you know I'm
so happy to be here this is where I got
my start and she's in the mirror with
the girls gonna have to get the liner to
be like this you know she was just one
of the girls so we had a great time with
her love her be four okay bingo
okay first thing you do when you wake up
hit the alarm and go back to sleep
[Music]
sounds like hocus-pocus you know what
ideas will double double toil and
trouble okay first thing Oh somebody's
funny over here at BuzzFeed first time
meeting your sugar daddy I don't have a
sugar daddy I never had a sugar daddy if
I want to sugar daddy yes I probably
won't get one cuz I'm what sick me that
was me and I got no sugar daddy didn't
say I didn't want one just said I don't
have one okay here we go oh the first
time bombing on stage well sister pick
one the biggest bomb on stage I think
that I've ever had was I was performing
in New York City at a club called
Providence that was open way back in the
day and it was Halloween and I remember
Snooki and JWoww were there they were
the hosts and I was doing a Halloween
know me you know I'm not really spooky
fish
but I was like I'm gonna give it to him
tonight so I came out there in my black
you know and I have on a mohawk I had
drawn from you know liner stuff on the
side of my face you know spooky the
music was going I said Oh imma give it
to him on this part so instead of doing
a regular death drop we all know
shangela knows the desktop okay I taught
it to the kids over on Dance Moms
lelou you know many chiropractors can
thank me for years of work and so I
decided to do a leaping helicopter just
drop soup and while I was in midair my
leg hit a prop coming down so I released
it early and instead of just doing the
regular d'etre I landed on the leg honey
and snap the tibia and the fibula bones
and the right leg on stage I would be
adrenaline when I hit the guy was like
and I was like yes I was feeling it I
tried to get back up girl couldn't move
the leg was foot know it was Providence
they didn't have no back exit so they
had to roll me through the dance floor
at the front door I remember leaving and
I was just waving to everybody like oh
my god Michelle are you okay
and I was like it's okay baby I'm good
I'll be back keep dancing halle-loo boo
first time meeting RuPaul okay actually
okay
everyone probably think that it was
RuPaul's Drag Race but it was not the
first time ever Paul was at a Christmas
party that Jennifer Lewis was having at
her house now I thought I was a guest
but I actually was there parking cars
this is true cuz you know I live in
Jennifer Lewis's basement she was like
baby when the people come tonight just
take the key honey and put the cars on
the street don't let the don't let them
walk baby Loretta's out there don't let
Loretta walk so I meant to go park one
car but then more cars just started
pulling out and just getting out and
handing me their keys so I didn't have
no sister I was just leaving the keys on
the sidewalk like while I ran and park
the car and RuPaul pulls up and RuPaul
has this beautiful red like little I
don't know if it was a convertible or
not but it's little you know and then
here comes RuPaul who's not little out
of this car and she's just was so tall
you know look at me was like huh angel
God whoa and she was like Hello Lucy
handed me the keys and kept on walking
but at the end of the night he needed
those keys back so in order to get him I
said can I get a picture first but he
was like of course yes of course and we
took that photo right outside on the
sidewalk honey hallelujah
and here's our final warrant I feel like
that lady on the Texas lotto which is
like the final number is
just a little extra camera time get that
green lovely can you ever go first
choice for all-stars for winner shangela
hallo Leute
now see this has been a fabulous
exhausting time alright I'm worn out I
don't think I got any first left the
tail but I will say thank you guys so
much for watching here at BuzzFeed and
make sure you check out the movie a star
is born okay
in theaters now it is sickening and I'm
in the movie halle-loo I'm working up a
sweat here dude the last time I wore
leather touch okay
[Music]